today the college has adopted its  opinions the three opinions  on the membership applications of  ukraine moldova and georgia  we have adopted these opinions after  very carefully assessing the merits  of each of these applications the merits  on the basis as you know of the  copenhagen criteria and the madrid  criterion  you might also know that these are  concerning the political criteria the  economic criteria and the question  whether the country the applicant has  the capacity to thrive in our very  competitive internal market  let me start with ukraine  the commission recommends to the council  first that ukraine is given european  perspective  and second that ukraine is given  candidate status  this is of course on the understanding  that the country will carry out a number  of further important reforms  and we all know  that ukrainians are ready to die for the  european perspective  we want them  to live with us the european dream  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  me  um  it's  you